(whimsical electronic music)
(clicking)
- One day, my family
was building this fence
around my chicken coop.
'Cause there were problems with raccoons.
And we wanted to make sure
that the perimeter of the fence
was twice the the length of the width.
And I remember thinking,
"This is exactly like my algebra class.
"I'm actually doing
things that are useful."
Algebra wasn't just something
that you do on paper,
it was actually protecting
the lives of my chickens.
So I felt like that was a moment for me
where math is useful to the world,
and we're solving real problems with it,
and it's really powerful.
- So I realized that
I first liked algebra,
and just math in general,
my first year in college,
I was a little bit of a late bloomer
in realizing the importance of math.
I was taking an early statistics course
for my psychology degree.
And I really began to understand
how the concepts that I were learning
could help me understand
the world around me better
in a more concrete, fluid, and rich way.
And so being able to make that connection
from these things that I'm
learning in the classroom
out into the real world,
so that I can under understand
different phenomenon,
I can understand how various
things in our culture
work and progress, really helped me
and made me feel like I
had a deeper understanding
for the importance of math and algebra.
And from that point I've
really been in love.